goo
今日はですね
僕はもともとい建築の勉強してきましたで生け花にひょんなことから出会いまして今
この道を歩んでいるところなんですけれども
今日はそんな僕が生け花華道間において大切だと思っていることを聞いていただきます
花
花なんですけれども
僕が考えている花ではですね感じの花ではないんです
田高楢原なんですね花を一言でいうと僕はあの
まあ関税と生命力とかきらびやかさとか
きらめきと呼んでいるんですこの煌めきを捕まえる8仕事をしてるのかなと今考えると
思っています
日本の喜びをと8ケージに代表されるものとして
松と竹と梅があります日本人が大切にしてきたですね
3つの植物なんですけれどもこの能楽堂の建築空間を見るとそれがよく理解できると
思います
後ろに早めにあるものが鏡板
ここに待つないがから
ています
右はですね切り餅の右側に書いてあるんですけども丈があります
で梅がこの中にあるんですねこれは何かというとこの舞台空間の中で回れる演者のこと
を上と呼びます
日本人はですね
僕が今言いましたきらめきとか
名力といったものを書き表すことができない一瞬の人
捉えているんです
僕が現地空間をずっと見てますとこの
松と竹と梅の扱い方
マットだけというものは a の生命の象徴なんです
なので建築の本そうですね a の生命を願いながら
ものを作るものですで埋め花はですね一瞬の日を作る
生命ログですこの2つ
日本人は日本の四季の中自然豊かな試験の中で
志してきました
花は普通の端ではなくキラメキなんです
こういった視点でですね僕は商業施設であるとか
ホテルのエントランス
建築のデザイン当たるまでこの煌めきを捕まえるために道や華道家として活動してい
ます
僕はですねいけばの志ていつも思うことがありますかどうかですと言うと何の職位をし
ている人なんですか
と言いまして
なかなか社会に根付いてないのが現状です
で
この現代社会において
日本人の自然観を培った想像力
生け花をもう少し社会に開いていきたいそういった活動を僕は夢見ています
でそういうことを考えたときに行けばなーですね
一言で僕がいい荒らすなら
死せるものを生き返らせる力なんじゃないかなと思っています
昔日本の民族はですね死んだ人にポツチーム埋めてですねその前で祈祷して本気で1回
下ろそうとしてきた
そういった歴史がありますそれはですねまあ日本人の死生観とかそういうものに
結びついているものなんですけれども
そういった価値の置かれてないものをしせるものですね
自分の想像力や
願いであるとかいろんなものをやっていき帰らする力が日本人にあると思っています
僕が3年前に静岡に行ってきていろんな山に里山の保全の方に連れて行ってもらいまし
た
山を見た瞬間にですね僕が思ったことはまずいということでした山はどんどんどんどん
荒廃して言ってるんです
東名高速道路を走りとですね右側に
竹林が鬱蒼としてましてあれがもう10年20年ぐらいで
ほんと面積二倍三が4倍に膨れ上がってるんです
先ほど言いました松竹梅 a の生命と一瞬の日を使いはけつぴた
日本人の繊細なその感性がその山によって
失われようとしているんです
これはお茶の木の根っこですがこれを作品として使ったこともありました
いろんな山を見てですねー
やはり僕は竹に目があの行ったんです
先ほど a の生命を願うものが
えっと松と竹といったんですけれども一瞬の日は梅なんです
丈は何かというとですね人間が心を通わすことのできる植物なんです
で僕はこの健夫ですねどうにかするために一本一本
里山保全の方や
林業を活性化することだちと一緒に
切ることにしました
それをですねー
ずっと切っていくんですね
1本芸術作品を使うための丈を着るために10本から20本の竹を切らないといけない
んです
ずーっと切っていくとですねこういう風な竹林にを願えるんです
これは戦術日本の庭園であった武雄
200本使った舞台美術なんですこれを作るためにですね
竹林を一閃本ぐらい切らないといけないんです
服のやっていることは多分微々たるもので中部から九州にかけてこの竹林の問題はある
んですけれども
多分や兄姉に水なんじゃないかなと思っています
でもこういう竹林の状況自然の状況を感じて言ってもらえるだけでも僕は彼恫喝として
の役割が十分あるんじゃないかなと思っています
竹林を切り出して舞台別に変えて
こういうふうに健夫竹チップにしていくんです
そうすると先ほどのような地区になります
そんな活動ずっとしていきながらある日チャンスがやってきました
フランスの方にですね能の舞台を作ってくれというオファーが来ました
これは日本の山の現場であったり
日本の美意識を世界に伝えるための
本当にチャンスなんじゃないかなと思いました
本当に人力でですねー
里山保全の方達と一生懸命その竹を切り出してそれをフランスに持って行きました
これがフランスの時の舞台の様子です
ここでですね三保の松原の代表曲でが羽衣の
の舞台美術をさせていただきました
僕の活動のことを見ていた人がですね循環型アートと言いました
循環型とアートこの2つが組み合わさるということは
日本の美意識が本当に反映したその造語だと思っています
アートというものがですね上から下にトップダウンで作られるものではなくて
て皆さんの日常の中に溶け込んでいって
いろんな
日に生活の日に置き換わることがとても僕は重要なんじゃないかなと思っています
今回もですねフェデックスの学生さんはじめ有志のみなさんと
このプロセスを得ました
一本一本みんなで力を合わせて竹を切りました
そこですごく気づいたことがありました
僕が循環型という生態系だったり
生命の循環そういったことを志していろいろやってきた言葉ですね
人と人の繋がり愛によって
社会資源を循環させるそういった動きになることも
今回できずことができました
学生さんが
静岡である
30分圏内で山に行ける場所にあるのに竹を知らないんです
多分静岡に住んでいる皆さんもたぶんこういう竹の現状とか山の現場はあまり知られて
ないんじゃないかなと思っています
そんな中でみんなと一緒に実はこの
だけを
舞台美術を作らさせていただけました
今日はですねこの舞台空間に最後花を生けて僕の登壇を終わりたいと思います
ん